but I think fetterman in the Senate is a
gift is a big big gift hear me hear me
people if the Republicans had the Senate
it would be better Iran sorry not wrong
Rand Paul would be chair of the health
uh committee or whatever I forgot the
full name and that means he's going to
be able to you know ask some serious
questions about fauci and all that stuff
because he's done it already but what
could they really do there's a chance
the Republicans will take the Senate
with the Georgia runoff we'll see
but with Fetter men in this means the
real prize 2024
it's it's it's it's fetterman's an
advantage think about all of the videos
that are going to come out all of the
memes all of and it's sad really I mean
I don't like it that Biden is out of his
mind that fetterman is is brain damaged
these people shouldn't have run but you
know what they did so now the now
they're the Democrats are going to get
to withstand they're gonna have to
figure out how to get past
two years of John fetterman not
understanding words